au moment où vous verrez cette vidéo je
serais arrivé à lausanne en suisse où je
joue donc ce soir techniquement c'est ce
soir pour vous demain et je repars
dimanche j'ai pas mal de choses de
calais dont un meetup allant prévisions
je vais tourner trois vidéos d'avant si
durant les prochains jours vous me voyez
dans la même position avec la même
lumière c'est que j'ai mis des trois
vidéos et sinon j'essaierais de tourner
là bas mais je ne sais jamais comment ça
se passe là diarra faut que suis parti
en tournée il n'y avait pas de wifi je
pouvais pas publier c'était une
catastrophe j'ai dû la télécharger en 3g
du coup la vidéo avait une heure et
demie de retard donc je vais être
prévoyant et aujourd'hui je me
transforme en boue cube puisque je vais
vous parler d'un mythe qui va vous
intéresser c'est pas un placement de
produit je vais acheter avec mes petits
sous j'avais envie d'en parler parce
qu'il est extrêmement bien
c'est le livre de génériques
ce n'est pas le livre de génériques
évidemment c'est le livre d'un certain
william alias doc seven il a sorti le
tour du monde des infos insolites faire
la curiosité n'est pas un vilain défaut
et je me suis demandé ce que ça pouvait
donner doc seven en livres que j'aime
beaucoup ces vidéos je regarde ce qu'il
fait depuis longtemps j'aime bien et
tout son schéma d'apprentissage marche
aussi avec l'image d'apprentissage et de
découverte donc naturellement je me suis
demandé si on pouvait transposer ça en
livre alors il a sorti ça un peu sous
forme de carnet de voyage c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que les coins sont arrondis
avec un petit vernis sélectif je crois
d'ailleurs que ça avait été la même
chose
voilà c'est ça pour les questions
concave et le vernis sélectif pareil car
très bon bouquin aussi mais je vais
parler plutôt de celui du william que de
celui d'hugo qui est très bien mais vous
allez comprendre pourquoi
déjà j'aime bien le principe que le
livre soit hors collection c'est à dire
que tout le livre a été créé pour lui ça
se sent ça se voit déjà toutes les
illustrations qui sont super et comme
dans les vidéos il a gardé le principe
17 donc ça va de cette fois est méconnu
à cet objet culte des années 2000 à 7
trésor introuvable il ya certaines
choses qu'on a déjà découvert dans ses
vidéos mais qui sont on va dire enrichi
mais franchement moi qui connaît bien la
chaîne la plupart des choses sont
inédites
le livre commence par une petite préface
elle est très courte ce sera sûrement
mon reproche en fait je j'espérais dans
le livre en savoir un peu plus posément
sur doc seven j'aurais bien aimé le lire
un peu plus longuement sur sur la
démarche de faire le livre et la
démarche de nous pousser à faire
découvrir des choses en les catégorisant
après c'est aussi un goût personnel
quand j'ouvre un livre jeu j'aime lire
les lélés les préfaces j'aime lire les
posts fasse aussi j'aime lire tout ce
qui n'a aucun rapport directement avec
le livre comme dans les vidéos ea
catégorise 2 sets à 1
donc 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 et après il n'y a pas
de règle tout dépend du contenu il l'a
pas écrit pour écrire donc en général ça
tient sur deux pages et des fois plus
trois quatre voire cinq pages quand je
lisais j'avais la boîte doc seven en
tête
donc ça c'était assez marrant en fait de
voir tellement imprégné que quand tu lis
le livre tu l'entends en fait en temps
son rythme et comme il ya mis sa manière
de parler des traits d'humour des choses
comme ça eh bien on récupère tout le ton
enrichi de ce qui fait sur youtube et ça
se retrouve vraiment la lecture
puisqu'on a des points d'exclamation un
peu partout des choses entre parenthèses
donc ça participe quand on subit
vocalises à bien entendre sa manière de
parler alors si vos qualités pour ceux
qui ne savent pas ce que ça veut dire
c'est quand on lit
dans sa tête consentants parler en
lisant on en avait parlé dans la vidéo
sur la lecture rapide que je vous invite
à découvrir si vous n'avez pas vu je
vous met une fiche ici ça se lit bien ça
sent mène partout je trouve ça cool en
fait les youtuber qui font des livres à
chaque fois j'y prends vraiment du
plaisir à voir les mettre dans un sac à
les lire dans les transports en commun
ou ailleurs c'est une autre manière de
les rencontrer c'est cool il ya soixante
choses différentes qui sont traités dans
le livre vert c'est pareil hein quoi tu
sais pas je sors un livre pour sortir un
livre il ya un vrai contenu en majeure
partie inédit avec plus de 60 sujets tu
sais qu'il ya des mois de boulot
derrière
et comme j'ai tendance à bien aimer tout
ce qui est goodies ou choses un peu
exclusive et c'est le fait d'avoir ça en
objet sous forme d'objets avoir voir un
livre quelque chose que je peux avoir
chez moi et rangé je trouve ça vraiment
cool je vous le dis dans les autres
livres dans le même style je l'avais
vraiment bien aimé celui des questions
qu'on est celui de bruce de la chaîne y
penser j'ai pas encore lu le 2 mai le
premier et excellent départ il doit dans
ma chambre celui ci voit la vidéo
différentes j'avais envie de vous parler
de ce livre parce que ça change un peu
parce qu on fait ce qu'on veut des fois
je faisais des rares sujets sur la
chaîne c'était hors sujet et pas tant
que ça parce qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de choses à apprendre et à
découvrir dans le bouquin donc c'est
cool j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
si c'est la première fois que vous êtes
sur la chaîne ou déjà quelques fois mais
que vous n'aviez pas encore pris le
temps n'hésitez pas à non vous abonner
également et n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner avant de partir puisque le
mental boxe et une vidéo par jour
pendant un an du 1er janvier au 31
décembre donc rendez vous demain à 11
heures le samedi c'est 11 heures ciao
là